andrew cuomo gave his state of the state
yesterday some people have called him
andrew cuovid
it's very mean but pretty pretty true
with andrew cuomo he has now
handled the virus worse than any
governor in the country he has kept the
state closed he sent six people into
nursing homes
he's wasted the vaccine he didn't
prepare correctly
he called in resources they didn't need
cuomo is now
saying after being closed up closed up
closed up all to no avail leads the
country
almost is it in the top three for death
and death rate on coronavirus
cuomo now says fellas we can't stay
closed
not
but we must do available smartly and
safely
did president trump write cuomo's speech
there did so
did a daily wire writer write cuomo's
state of the state
what have we been saying now for months
and months and months we've said you
have to reopen
if you don't reopen soon there's not
going to be anything to reopen
many it kills me i'm a new yorker myself
born and raised
many of the great establishments of new
york are not going to reopen i think
it's some
it's expected that the majority of
restaurants in new york
are not going to reopen very sad what
he's done
to a generally speaking beautiful and
vibrant city
and now cuomo says now we got to reopen
yeah because your policy didn't work
because your lockdown policy didn't work
because your vaccine rollout
certainly didn't work it was a complete
disaster
it andrew cuomo because of his stupid
policies not only got
grandma killed you know not only got
thankfully not my grandmothers
but lots of people's grandmothers killed
in new york
but andrew cuomo is now wasting the
vaccine because he put policies into
effect
that said that if healthcare workers did
not follow his guidelines
for exactly who to give the vaccine to
they could be fined they could face very
steep punishments
so do you know what was happening health
care workers were throwing out the
vaccine
because they didn't want to face the
state government penalties
finally now cuomo is lifting extremely
idiotic regulation too but but while
everyone's focusing on that part of the
state of the state i actually want to
focus in
on another statement which i think did
not get the kind of coverage it should
but it tells you exactly what the left
is after with these onerous and
draconian lockdown policies
today i'm speaking in person with a
small group
but broadcasting zooming and streaming
and in this new and different world the
audience is actually larger
not smaller technology and
technology-based relationships work from
home
these are new realities that will have
dramatic
consequences this next year we will see
economies realign
and reset around the world we see
the risk in the peril but we also see
the promise and the potential
the question to be answered is what will
we make of this moment
is it positive or is it negative do we
move forward or do we move
backward is america is new york
stronger or weaker in the post-covered
world
those my friends are the questions that
we
alone will answer in 2021 because the
future is in
our hands
america and new york will be stronger in
the postcovid world if we run these
lunatic sociopath politicians out on a
railway line
and they will be weaker in the postcovid
world
if we follow what these people want to
do
the left does not want to go back to
normal the
left wants this to be the new normal
andrew cuomo just stated it explicitly
he said look usually we have an audience
usually i'm accountable to people in the
audience usually i have to answer
questions from people who are live
but now they're all on zoom isn't that
so much better i'm reaching more people
first of all i don't really see how
that's the case you could easily have a
zoom camera going
while having people in the room you're
just giving people more opportunities
and not everybody uses zoom i assure you
my grandmother
does not get on zoom every single day
does not know what zoom is my
grandmother in new york doesn't
doesn't use a computer and i think
that's true for a lot of people
so no i don't think it's it's uh
the way forward is to limit spaces that
people
get to interact with their politicians
no what about
working from home he says this is the
new reality you're all going to start
working from home
say business is a lot of money on office
space you just work work work
it worked very well i read one study
that said that people are working
more actually you think that when people
work from home they would work less
actually productivity
has increased in many places
that's the new reality is it you know
there's a
theory going on speaking of all these
sort of gnostic theories going around
the internet
they say that covet is the great reset
and this is supposed to be some grand
conspiracy theory it's not a grain
conspiracy theory the guy's talking
about it right there
he says we're going to reset but it's
going to be a re the economies are going
to realign they're going to reset
based on what happened with kovid we're
going to have new norms for society and
that's it
we're not going to gather as often as we
want to we're going to be on
zoom we're going to be wearing masks
certainly when we travel we're going to
be wearing masks a whole lot more not
going to see people smiling faces
we're going to muzzle ourselves out in
public
we're going to work from home much more
not going to go in and see people at the
office
not going to go have human interaction
just lock ourselves away in our rooms
and zoom all day long does that sound
like a fulfilling life
does that sound like the kind of society
you want to live in
not me not me if you enjoyed that video
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
you